j'accueille caroline loeb
[Musique]
la ruse a raison seul et paris serait ce
vraiment la paresse ou trop de couacs
est
apparemment
[Musique]
c'est la plus heureuse
paresseuse
les matières c'est la ouate qu'elle
préfère est si belle 106
négligé de soir la foi de toutes les
matières c'est la ouate qu'elle préfère
massive l évangile
tout le monde en a parlé à retrouver
caroline loeb dans le 20e arrondissement
de paris signe particulier caroline est
une collectionneuse voilà donc partout
où je vais je chope des trucs d'opus par
terre et à quoi donc lui servent tous
ces trésors de guerre lourd j'ai un
spectacle que je tourne depuis deux ans
qui est donc mistinguett madonna et moi
quand j'arrive sur scène j'arrive avec
effectivement des colliers genre genre
c'est moi et en plus c'est un côté un
peu armure ya un côté un peu cotte de
maille ça fait du et de toutes les
matières laquelle elle préfère c'est
terrible des chapeaux que je chope de ci
de là peut-être choses basiques je me
semble incroyablement à audrey hepburn
on me le dit souvent donc le chapeau
claque ce qui est merveilleux en fait
voilà comment ces escaliers attendez
c'est pas possible qu'importe caroline
se pressent pour retrouver le glamour de
sa boutique préférée dans les
arrière-cours du paris des cabarets
ailleurs
on
va récupérer un éventail pour mon
spectacle mistinguett madonna et moi qui
a été malencontreusement cas c'est que
j'ai dû faire changer quelques plumes
j'adore aller chez le plumassier
quelquefois je croise les les assistants
deux
assistants grands couturiers qui
viennent choisir des coups magnifiques
bonjour et vite
je dois en fait voir de toutes les
couleurs à cet éventail 1 parce que
c'est vrai que j'étais un passage dans
mon spectacle je dis que j'ai un point
commun avec mistinguett c'est que
j'adore les plumes et après je pars dans
un délire comme ça au jeu le jeu lui
olala je peux plus faire comme avant dit
donc
je le m oui c'est zizi jeanmaire aussi
évidemment zizi jeanmaire l exception en
hervé yeuse
non
j'adorerais brin truc comme ça des 110
cali avec des filles autour j'adore sa
voix j'espère a pas trop bientôt ils
appartiennent quand même
merci mademoiselle au revoir
après présenter une revue j'adore ça
parce que quand même une dame comme
ligne à liliane tv qui est là elle a
fait ça chez pas jusqu'à 70 à 75 ans
joséphine baker elle a fait ça jusqu'à
la fin de sa vie plus 70 balais et
marlène a chanté jusqu'à 75 m 28 ans et
des femmes qui ont continué vraiment
jusqu'au bout même si exigeant mère je
les ai vus aux bouffes du nord j'étais
en larmes c'était tellement tellement
beau
tellement élégant tellement piquant
j'adorerais face à nouveau je le sais je
ferai mon spectacle en version lite on
va dire
caroline fils dans les rues de la
capitale direction le studio
d'enregistrement où elle doit finaliser
ces projets dont un avec sa grande
copine isabelle alonso
[Musique]
enfin on voyait des travaux 1
s'est ouvert voix elle retrouve laurent
son directeur artistique depuis quinze
ans caroline est une fidèle et quelles
sont ses autres qualités si
délicieusement ce north à défaut que je
dois pour la négociation commence quand
on me dit non tu peux le dire ce que tu
peux enfin et l'on retrouve gérald
l'accordéoniste de son spectacle depuis
un an les histoires que je vis
et celle que j'invente all in ce qui est
séduisant chez elle c'est qui au elle
n'abandonne jamais donc on n'a pas le
choix quand on a envie qu'elle soit on
prend le train et qu'elle soit on va sur
le quai et dans ce cas là on la voit
partir et on regrette parce que avec
caroline on n'est jamais déçu les
américains tels j'envoie des renaissants
prince
la renaissance parce que ces gens qui
font plein de choses la renaissance
c'est bien mais la reconnaissance ne lui
monte t elle pas
[Musique]
et maintenant la lumière se rallume sur
caroline loeb
carline bienvenus donc on a parlé
bonjour thierry ça va super alors
caroline faisait tenir le 5 octobre 1955
à neuilly sur seine quand vous naissez
votre famille habite encore à paris près
du palais royal mais plus pour très
longtemps en effet votre grand père
était un marchand d'art exceptionnels il
star dans le monde de la peinture ce qui
fait que quand votre père veut monter sa
galerie de peinture pour exister dix ans
il le fait à new york en kit paris quand
j'ai quatre ans et on va s'installer à
new york pour six ans et je passe donc
vraiment ce qui est l'enfance mon
enfance à new york devant central park
on à la nature sous les fenêtres je
voyais mon père faire du ski en bas le
bonhomme de neige qu'on l'avait fait le
matin on le voyait du 52e étage alors
après l'aventuré américaine votre
famille revient s'installer à paris rue
michel-ange dans le xvième à l'époque
vous découvrez la musique j'écoute et
henri salvador boby lapointe oui mais
aussi beaucoup d'opéras que j'avais déjà
commencé à écouter beaucoup à new york à
l'époque quand vous écoutez de l'opéra
vous pensez déjà à la mise en scène
est super dit rencardé
en fait je me foutais à l'opéra je me
défonce et à l'opéra je me défoncer à
verdi à mozart dire que c'est tellement
fort cette musique c'est c'est tellement
de puissance et des émotions hyper
violente et moi ça je me souviens avoir
l'éviter sur rigoletto mais vraiment ce
que tu es au plafond et c'est là que
j'ai eu mes premières visions de mise en
scène c'est sur la ria de donner le veer
dans don juan mais la réalité est plus
prosaïque à la fin des années soixante
dix après avoir quitté la fac vous vous
retrouvez vendeuse chez kenzo
quelques mois à la fac de vincennes et
je m'emmerde et enfin en fait j'avais
envie de bosser j'avais envie de voir
les mains dans le cambouis j'avais envie
de faire des choses donc je me retrouve
vendeuse chez kenzo et je paye avec ça
je paye mes cours de théâtre au cours
florent voilà le problème c'est que vous
raté trois fois le conservatoire enfin
le problème l'eau c'est pas un problème
ben non il ya plein de gens très bien
qui ont raté le conservatoire et qui ont
raté plusieurs fois en fait avec le
recul je pense qu'on apprend plus de
choses dans la vraie vie que dans les
cours sur alors ce n'est qu'à 23 ans
vous montrer enfin sur les planches avec
succès une pièce écrite par le mari de
paloma picasso pas de mât picasso qui
est fait derrière les décors et les
costumes à tous de se faire prêter ce
troll ensuite a fait ses deux garçons
qui venait de bonnes odeurs qui ont
fondé le groupe c avec avec arias et
avec martial béraud donc c'est vraiment
la bande des argentins à paris qui avait
fui bender et qui ont vraiment rien
inventé le théâtre donc en fait je leur
ai dit que je travaille avec vous ils
m'ont écrit sept rôles et voilà c'était
une speakerine juliette de roméo
juliette la fille de lana turner enfin
des rôles très différents et ça
s'appelait succès mais ça n'a pas été un
alors là le patron désir corde ce
produit votre premier album qui va nana
avec les musiciens le kid créole très
très bien il trouve au texte
gainsbourien donc il va il plonge alors
je trouve en fait enregistré à new york
dans un studio qui s'appelle el aidi
world qui est le lieu de jimi hendrix
donc c'était c'était extraordinaire pour
moi de me retrouver à new york à faire
ce disque bon maintenant c'est vrai que
c'est la première fois que je rentrais
dans un studio de
l'enregistrement que c'est pas un milieu
où on vous explique tellement les choses
les gens sont pas très gentils donc
voila c'était assez violent truc assez
violent qui est un peu perdue quand même
oui j'étais un peu perdue c'est vrai je
la vis la vie vous meniez en dehors des
studios s'étaient pas non plus de tout
repos se souvient entre autres deux
derniers mx2 dernier titre de l'album
qui s'appelait narcissique monde et l
effet
est fêté jeudi êtes en train de démolir
ce fameux dernier studio de jimi hendrix
donc il y avait des gravats partout les
fils qui pendait nous on était
complètement défoncée et on a fait un
mix mais c'est la meilleure chanson de
l'album narcissique avec un truc
complètement barré en attendant on avait
l'impression d'entendre le fantôme
d'être excitée c'était fou et le
résultat est vachement bien mais l'album
ne marche pas non l'album marche pas
alors je n'oublierai jamais une critique
de jeanne folie je crois qu'ils avaient
dit que je chantais comme un petit
cochon qu'on égorge
beaucoup rire et ça me fait toujours
rire trente ans après et c'est vrai qu'à
l'époque j'étais trop trop 20 trobar est
trop floue nous voilà le résultat c'est
que les chansons sont vachement bien je
regrette de ne pas avoir pu refaire les
voix pour dire voilà avec une pochette
quand même de mondino we are justement
vous donnez styliste pour la photo pour
la mode avec mondino et vous participez
aux pochettes de chant ford de téléphone
de fait un livre avec gainsbourg qui
s'appelle bon bout et les bouquets
styliste absolument c'était ça reste
quand même
à mes yeux d'avoir été chez lui rue de
verneuil avait peu vous êtes maître que
le besoin c'est vraiment la grande
époque du night club où vous êtes le
pilier des nuits parisiennes la preuve
c'est que quand les bains douches ouvre
ses vous l'attaché de presse j'avais
commencé au club 7 à 7 ans puis le
palace avec la brise de mer et donc
j'avais un carnet d adresses évidemment
de tous les gens qui sortaient et
fabrice coâté et jacques renaud m'ont
demandé de faire l'ouverture et
l'ouverture des bains-douches je suis
pas si j'étais 28 y était je pense que
tu te souviens des ce qui était
incroyable c'est que la peinture était
pas sèche et je sais que toutes ces
disputes ces dames avaient emprunté des
fringues chez mugler chez gaultier les
repartez avec de la peinture sur le
vêtement donc c'était une fête géniale
mais
c'était voilà c'était l'endroit n'était
pas fini alors c'est avec un copain de
deux virées nocturnes dans cette pierre
grillet que vous écrivez paresseuse mise
en musique par philippe chami de toutes
les matières c'est la ouate qu'elle
préfère indépassable ça c'est une phase
où c'est une phrase de pierre grillet
enfin en fait il arrivé chez moi un jour
avec un son petit carnet enfin comme
tous les gens qui écrivent les petits
carnets avec des notes avec quelques
phrases et j'ai tout de suite flashé sur
ces phrases il y en avait d'autres y
avait jose pour le soft dit elle je sais
pas quoi et toutes les photos des leçons
des photos couchers voilà c'était
vraiment c'était évocateur politique
l'image d'une femme comme sa nonchalance
qui se laissent aller et et g et créer
la deuxième partie du refrain le dernier
couplet la moitié du bois là et je
bidouille et le truc et c'est devenu ce
texte que chami a mis en musique etc
sont guy miclo ouais voilà alors
personne n'en veut c'est ça qui est
incroyable toutes les maisons de disques
eux refusent de faire le disque saut
philippe constantin gloire lui soit
rendue chez barclays et là ça devient un
tube nous les que ça sort c'est la
traînée de poudre ou du délire même cité
par mitterrand dans une interview avec
moi aussi absolument il était très était
très branché à mi-temps après j'étais
déjeuner à l'elysée un foie et à vaquer
attali sai alliés sur le cash patti et
tout ça les amusait beaucoup tout ça
alors donc vous devenu célèbre assez
rapidement finalement les attachés de
presse je me souviens il disait mais on
n'a jamais vu ça c'est à dire qu'en
général un attaché de presse ça rame
pour avoir des télés des radios de la
presse et où l'asie qui décrochèrent
banos là elle peut pas oui là elle peut
c'était incroyable donc effectivement
jeu pendant deux ans je n'ai plus fait
que sa télé radio photo la loi est la
loi de la boîte à jusqu'à un peu jusqu'à
la nausée quand même au bout d'un moment
quelles ont été les réactions de vos
parents par exemple
il était comme tout le monde
pétrifié par ce succès mon père
m'appelait la ouate
non mais la vérité c'est que quand tout
à coup on est pris dans un tel
tourbillon tellement violent je dis
toujours les la télé ces écrans c'est
vrai ça le fait avec tout le monde c'est
pas vrai qu'avec un succès comme ça tout
le monde vous regarde pareil
le regard change et à force que le
regard des autres change pas son regard
change aussi on finit par pu très bien
savoir où on habite donc voilà c'est pas
simple vos amis engagés comme en
bas tout le monde est très content
berlin tente ou non dégrisé tout le
monde et tout pète un câble alors soi
même on en paix tu as aussi mais autour
tout le monde tout le monde est fou quoi
parce que parce que c'est une histoire
de fou parce qu'on n'est jamais libre
parce qu on est tout le temps on est
tout le temps en train de parler deux
fois on est tout le temps en train de de
d'être félicité par des gens qui vous
trouve absolument merveilleux on trouve
ça merveilleux évidemment heureusement
ils ont pas d comment ils s'en sont pas
rendu compte avant ce gp un génie donc
voilà tout ça ça devient une espèce de
truc complètement fou quoi bon rapport
avec les médias c'était comment
ba s'était dit l'icg c'était formidable
les médias madoré je les faisais rien
j'étais super bonne cliente je répondais
à tous de devan bon moi j'adorais sans
moi j'adorais ça la promo un peu comme
gainsbourg pour moi c'est un autre un
autre média de création c'est très
amusant l'argent à gagner du pognon moi
j'ai connu tout va bien sûr ouais enfin
bon ça se dépense facilement
et l'amour est ce que ça vous a rapporté
plein de beaux garçons cette histoire
caries non c'est pas comme ça non
d'abord le succès se vit quand même très
différent suivant qu'on soit un homme ou
une femme je crois le côté les groupies
et tout je crois que les mecs en
profitent bien quand on est une fille
une fille pas du tout les choses de la
même manière non par an plus tôt les
choses plus compliquées ça rend pas les
choses plus si vous appelez des sceaux
plan sentimental
pas vraiment non peux pas dire le
meilleur moment de toute cette époque
c'était quoi c'était une télé en italie
parce que bon c'est la ouate a été
numéro un en italie mais détaille les
italiens et c'était nous a coûté
sérialisé main tard et avec cette
chanson faisait bref mon plus beau
souvenir c'était donc en italie à sienne
sur la grande place de sienne qui est
juste un des plus beaux endroits du
monde où il y avait le palier au moyen
âge et avais une scène c'est une grande
et l'italienne et j'arrive sur le
plateau je commence à chanter la chanson
et il ya devant moi je sais pas 5000
10000 personnes qui la chante du premier
au dernier mot
c'était inouï c'est inouï j'étais quand
même emporté
on a été tellement beau et le pire
moment de cette époque et un peu
l'embarras du choix away
we hill et les les coulisses de tout ça
était et emin pas très marrante pas très
marrante derrière tout ça il y avait
quand même beaucoup de souffrance
voilà quand on est devant et comprend la
lumière il ya des gens qui sont pas
devant qui prennent pas la lumière qui
s'ouvre donc voila c'était s'était pas
c'était pas évident le revers de la
médaille c'est les problèmes que vous
avez eue avec un des co créateur de la
chanson oui tout ça a été très compliqué
ouais c'est pour des raisons d'argent
pour des raisons de reconnaissance
médiatique le ballet de les deux
ce qui était terrible aussi à la sortie
de ça c'est que vous n'étiez pas une
chanteuse en fait j'étais une chanson
j'étais devenu un trou avec du vinyle
autour de se chercher ma pochette parler
me coucher est mort
c'est quand même moyen ouais mais c'est
assez a cristallisé sa fille voilà voilà
votre votre vie quoi d'une certaine
façon oui et puis enfin le problème
c'est surtout que je suis une artiste
donc ma vie d'artiste elle n'a pas
commencé assez la boîte et surtout pas
arrêté à ces la boîte donc c'est un peu
particulier à gérer des moments où quand
même on a l'impression d'être d'être fou
quoi parce que les gens vous renvoie un
truc enzymes attend chez moi je suis pas
une chanson bon déjà je suis pas une
chanteuse non je suis pas une chanson
vous êtes retrouvé coincé dans un tube
we à un temps un temps alors le retour
sur terre après tout ça ça a été comme
en violant bah oui parce qu'on part à
trois milles à l'heure
c'est complètement crise ans est fou
c'est c'est extraordinaire et puis on
voit pas le mur arrivée et puis
cela prend quoi mais d'une certaine
manière je suis contente que les choses
se soient arrêtées avec ce show biz
cette variété etc
mais j'ai retrouvé
c'est la mise en scène qui a sauvé la
mise en scène qui m'a sauvé la vie à
près du mans est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous
êtes nostalgique de cette époque de la
ouate
le contraire de nostalgiques
annonce chaque jour qui passe m'éloigne
de cette époque et ça la rend au choix
oui non parce que franchement ce que je
fais maintenant est beaucoup plus fort
beaucoup plus profond c'est beaucoup
plus
riche parce que moi seras-tu comme ça
c'est magique c'est extraordinaire enfin
c'est quand même que 3 minutes 30 c'est
quand même qu'une page et demie texte
fut tu vois je veux dire c'est quand
même mais ma vie d'artiste est beaucoup
plus riche depuis quinze ans que qu'avec
elle n'était avant le tube non si
c'était à refaire qu'est-ce que vous ne
referiez pas pareil
je prendrai un bon avocat
et je ferai attention à ce que je signe
c'est vrai qu'à l'époque
blanc je signais je n'avais rien à
[ __ ] puis je pouvais pas imaginer que
ça allait être aussi fou cette histoire
alors s'il fallait trouver une épitaphe
pour vous qu'est-ce que vous marquerez
un grand pas pour moi un petit pour
l'humanité
j'avais trouvé un truc qui est énoncé la
vie c'est pas coton oui aussi oui bien
d'écouter merci au revoir caroline
j'étais très heureux de ramener la
lumière sur vous moi j'espère qu'elle va
pas cet homme tout de suite quand on va
laisser la lumière allumée merci et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux